- HOMIE SAID
YOU AIN'T GOT NO BITCHES.
- WHO DON'T GOT NO BITCHES?
HE SAID--HE SAID I DON'T?
YOU KNOW, BOO,
SHE LOVE THIS.
SHE WANT THIS FINE ASS
MOTHER[BLEEP].
[BLEEP].
COME ON, BOO.
I'M FAMOUS AS A MOTHER [BLEEP]
OUT HERE.
- YOU FAMOUS, HUH, WELVEN?
- HELL, YEAH.
TAKE MY NUMBER DOWN.
WE CAN CHAT.
CUZ, SOMETHING CAME
IN THE MAIL TODAY.
[MAN MURMURS INDISTINCTLY]
DEEZ NUTS.
HA!
GOT HIM!
[LAUGHING]
- THE IMPORTANT THING IS THAT
WE'RE LAUGHING WITH HIM.
MEET WELVEN DA GREAT.
HE'S AN INSTAGRAM LEGEND,
A MEME,
AND A POSSIBLE VICTIM
OF FETAL ALCOHOL SYNDROME.
A REAL PIECE OF WORK...
SPECIFICALLY A PICASSO PAINTING.
WELVEN IS FAMOUS
FOR HIS DEEZ NUTS PRANK CALLS.
HE'S A LIVING
"CRANK YANKERS" PUPPET.
BUT UNLIKE THAT SHOW,
HE ACTUALLY MAKES ME LAUGH.
IF YOU'RE UNFAMILIAR WITH
HIS PARTICULAR BRAND OF COMEDY,
IT'S BECAUSE YOU'RE
A HONKY-ASS CRACKER.
LIKE MISSISSIPPI, THE INTERNET
IS STILL SEGREGATED.
THE BLACK INTERNET IS WAY BETTER
THAN THE WHITE INTERNET.
I'M GUESSING IT'S ALSO FASTER,
PROBABLY BIGGER.
WHITE PEOPLE
HAVE ETSY AND HUFFPO.
BLACK PEOPLE HAVE WORLDSTAR
AND LIDS.COM.
JUST DON'T CONFUSE THE BLACK
INTERNET WITH THE DARK WEB.
THAT'S WHERE ISIS GOES
TO SEND OUT E-VITES.
FOR THE RECORD, WELVEN DIDN'T
INVENT DEEZ NUTS JOKES.
DR. DRE DID.
BUT "STRAIGHT OUTTA COMPTON"
CONVENIENTLY GLOSSED OVER THAT,
AS WELL AS THE MANY WOMEN
WHO GOT BEATS BY DRE.
DEEZ NUTS
ARE SO BIG RIGHT NOW,
REPUBLICANS WANT THEM
TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT.
I'D LOVE TO HAVE A PRESIDENT
WITH A BULLDOG'S FACE
AND A HUGE SET OF TESTICLES.
THAT'S WHY I'M VOTING
FOR HILLARY.
WELVEN LIVES EVERY DAY
LIKE IT'S APRIL FOOL'S DAY,
AND I RESPECT THAT.
IN FACT,
I MENTALLY CHALLENGE YOU
TO FIND A BIGGER BALLER
ON THE INTERNET.
I HAVE A DREAM THAT PEOPLE OF
ALL RACES ARE READY FOR WELVEN.
THAT'S WHY I SENT AN ESCALADE
TO LONG BEACH
TO PICK UP
THAT HUMAN PEZ DISPENSER
FOR THIS WEEK'S
CE-WEB-RITY PROFILE.
[TELEPHONE RINGS]
- [MURMURS INDISTINCTLY]
WHAT'S GOOD?
- YES, CAN I SPEAK TO THE HEAD
OF THE HOUSEHOLD
ABOUT DEEZ NUTS!
HA-HA!
GOT HIM.
- THAT'S DUMB.
- WHAT UP, WELVEN?
WHERE YOU GONNA BE TONIGHT?
- I'M AT THE CLUB.
- OH, CAN YOU GET ME
ON THE LIST?
- I GOT YOU.
- ♪ ALL OUT
LIKE JANET AT THE SUPER BOWL ♪
- WHO DON'T GOT
NO BITCHES?
- WELVEN, YOU SHOULDN'T TALK
LIKE THAT TO LADIES.
IT'S VERY DISRESPECTFUL.
- STOP ACTING
LIKE A BITCH.
- YEAH, BITCH!
- HUH.
- [LAUGHS]
- BUBBLY?
YOU SHOULDN'T HAVE.
LOOKS LIKE YOU GOT THE CLUB
GOING UP ON TUESDAY.
WELVEN DA GREAT.
HOW'D YOU GET THAT NAME?
- THAT'S MY INSTAGRAM NAME.
THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE
ALWAYS CALLED ME.
- YOU SLEEPY?
YOU AT THE--
YOU TIRED AT THE CLUB?
- NAH.
- WHERE YOU FROM?
- LONG BEACH.
- LONG BEACH?
WHAT'S IT LIKE TO BE THE
OFFICIAL FACE OF DEEZ NUTS?
- THAT'S MY FAVORITE LINE,
AND I ALWAYS LIKE TO SAY IT.
- GOD, IT'S GOOD.
IT'S GOOD.
IT NEVER GETS OLD.
- NO, IT DON'T.
- WERE YOU SURPRISED
THAT YOU GOT SO POPULAR?
- HELL YEAH.
- HAS CALLER ID
RUINED YOUR GAME?
- NO.
- PEOPLE KNOW IT'S YOU CALLING.
- [LAUGHS]
THEY KNOW.
- THEY DON'T EVEN CARE?
- MM-MM.
- WHAT'D YOU THINK
OF KENDRICK LAMAR
STEALING YOUR NAME ON THAT
VIDEO WITH TAYLOR SWIFT?
- I DIDN'T SEE IT.
- STRAIGHT UP
JACKED YOUR NAME.
- I GOT TO SEE IT FIRST.
- I'M LETTING YOU KNOW.
HOW'D YOU COME UP WITH,
"WHO DON'T GOT NO BITCHES?"
DID SOMEBODY ACCUSE YOU
OF NOT HAVING ANY BITCHES?
- WELVEN, THE HOMIE SAID
YOU AIN'T GOT NO BITCHES.
- WHO DON'T GOT NO BITCHES?
- YOU'VE ALWAYS HAD BITCHES.
- ALWAYS.
- SINCE DAY ONE.
HOW MANY BITCHES YOU GOT?
- A LOT.
- HOW MANY BITCHES
YOU GOT, BALLPARK?
- A LOT.
- ♪ BO, BO-A-BO ♪
♪ A-BO-BO ♪
♪ BO-A-BO, A-BO-BO ♪
- YOU EVER MADE LOVE
TO AN OLD WOMAN?
LIKE, SOMEBODY OVER 50?
YOU EVER TAKE IT DOWN?
- [LAUGHS]
NO, AND NEVER WANT TO.
- AH.
OKAY.
WHAT'S THE--
I LIKE THAT YOU COVER
YOUR MOUTH WHEN YOU YAWN.
- [LAUGHS]
- YOU GET RECOGNIZED
WHEN YOU GO OUT?
PEOPLE KNOW WHO YOU ARE?
- MM-HMM.
- THEY WANT TO TAKE
PHOTOS WITH YOU?
- YEAH,
BUT I CHARGE AND--
- YOU CHARGE PEOPLE
FOR PHOTOS?
MUCH RESPECT.
OKAY, IT'S A HOT GIRL.
SHE WANTS TO GET
A PHOTO WITH YOU.
YOU GONNA CHARGE HER?
- NO.
- SHE'S FREE.
- ONLY DUDES.
- DUDES HAVE TO PAY.
- YEAH.
- WHITE DUDES HAVE TO PAY
MORE THAN BLACK DUDES?
- [LAUGHS]
- DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
NEW CATCHPHRASES?
- UH...
[YAWNS]
- I'M GONNA
LET YOU FINISH.
- [LAUGHS]
YOU KNOW MALONG,
RIGHT?
- CARL?
- NO, MALONG.
- NO, WHAT'S MALONE?
- MALONG DICK.
- OH, YOUR LONG DICK.
I GOT IT.
MALONG DICK.
- YOU KNOW TIP, RIGHT?
- TIP, WHO?
- TIP OF THIS DICK.
- OH!
- [GUFFAWS]
HEY, YOU KNOW BOFA?
- BOFA WHO?
- BOFA DEEZ NUTS.
[BOTH LAUGHING]
YOU KNOW CANDACE, RIGHT?
- CANDACE WHO?
- CANDACE [BLEEP] FIT
IN YOUR MOUTH?
- POSSIBLY.
[BOTH LAUGHING]
I GOT A BIG MOUTH.
- BUT NOT--
NOT ON MINE, YOU KNOW?
- OKAY, OH, NO,
WHAT I--
YOU JUST ASKED A QUESTION.
- NO.
- YOU ASKED A QUESTION.
- I JUST SAID, JUST...
- NOT LIKE THAT,
THOUGH.
- NO, I'M NOT
GONNA DO IT.
BUT I'M JUST SAYING
COULD IT.
YOU SAID COULD--
CAN IT FIT?
YES, TECHNICALLY,
IT CAN.
- OH, OKAY.
- I DON'T WANT IT TO.
- OH, OKAY,
JUST MAKING SURE.
- OKAY?
IS YOUR REFRIGERATOR RUNNING?
- YEAH.
- YEAH, YOU BETTER GO CATCH IT.
[LAUGHING]
OH, SORRY.
WELVEN, IF I GIVE YOU
$10 MILLION RIGHT NOW,
WHICH I'M NOT DOING,
ALL RIGHT?
- I THOUGHT YOU WERE.
- NO, NO, NO, BUT IF I
GIVE YOU $10 MILLION,
WHAT ARE YOU
GONNA SPEND IT ON?
- CLOTHES, SHOES,
SHIRTS, JEANS, SOCKS.
- ALL RIGHT, SO YOU GOT
WARDROBE TAKEN CARE OF.
YOU EVER GROW A FULL BEARD?
- UH-UH.
[YAWNS]
- YOU EVER HAVE A NAP?
YOU LIKE NAPS?
I LIKE A NAP EVERY DAY.
- NO, I COULD JUST BE
KNOCKED OUT RIGHT NOW, LIKE...
- SURE.
THERE'S THREE
CAMERAS ON YOU.
WHAT BETTER TIME
TO TAKE A NAP?
WHERE DO YOU SEE YOURSELF
IN TEN YEARS?
- I SEE EVERYTHING RIGHT NOW.
- I SEE YOU ON DEEZ NUTS.
[LAUGHS]
IF YOU HAD ONE THING TO TELL
THE HATERS, WHAT WOULD IT BE?
WE GOT TO GET YOU
ON A BETTER SCHEDULE.
WELVEN, THERE'S NO DENYING
THAT YOU ARE KILLING IT
ON THE WRONG SIDE
OF THE TRACKS,
BUT I THINK IT'S TIME
FOR YOU TO CROSS OVER.
AND NOBODY LIKES NUTS
MORE THAN WHITE PEOPLE.
WE'RE ABOUT TO TAKE DEEZ
TO THE MAINSTREAM.
- DEEZ WHO?
[PERCUSSIVE MUSIC]
♪ ♪
Y'ALL WITH THE LAPD?
[JAZZY SAXOPHONE MUSIC]
LAP DEEZ NUTS.
[LAUGHS]
[HIP-HOP MUSIC]
MALE ANNOUNCER:
WELVEN DA GREAT DOES IT
POLICE BRUTALITY STYLE.
- GOT 'EM.
♪ ♪
ANNOUNCER: GET CRACKIN'.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
- NOW THAT KEY AND PEELE
HAVE BROKEN UP,
IT'S BACK ON ME
TO REPRESENT THE BLACK COMMUNITY
HERE AT COMEDY CENTRAL.
I'M CERTAINLY NOT
GONNA LEAVE IT
UP TO LARRY AND TREVOR.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK,
BUT FIRST,